we recently had the chance to check out
crimson heist the latest update coming
to rainbow six siege
alex van aaken of gameinformer joins me
to break down the new character the
changes to border and the new equipment
if you enjoyed this video don't forget
to hit that like and subscribe
anyway let's get to it so i guess just
to start out the new operator here is
flores his gadget is the rce
reterocharge drone which is basically an
explosive drone
he's equipped with the ar-33 and sr-25
the his secondary is the gsh18
his equipment is stun grenade and
claymore and those are the
big things for flores yeah both of us
had the chance to play him
i mean overall what'd you think of him i
liked him he you know flores isn't
typically
my style of play um more of you know an
explosives expert you know taking down
soft
walls um i typically you know rather
than other sorts of characters but
his kit is really interesting because
there's a lot of things that you can do
with that explosive drone there's a lot
of like
little tips and tricks that you can kind
of employ to kind of maximize his
efficiency with those items jumping onto
walls before you
time his remote explosive a lot of cool
stuff like that but what do you think
jake
i had fun with him he i think he was
more interesting to play against than he
was to play as because whenever that
drone would show up
in the bomb room or whatever i would
drop what i was doing sprint out the
door
and just cower and it's not even that
big of an explosion but it's
big enough to really mess you up if
you're caught in it it's just an instant
kill yeah but i actually found out while
playing him
trying to get kills with the drone
wasn't always the best idea
i found it better to almost use that as
a diversion or
to trick the defenders drive that in
there
set it off and that would immediately
cause the defenders to do what i was
just describing and
run out the door and meanwhile i'd just
be waiting out there with my gun
and i'd pop them as they ran by which
seemed to work pretty well for me
yeah i was we were playing on uh border
which
has some changes we'll get to in a
little bit but um yeah we were on
defense
and uh flores was just kept it might
even been you that was playing flores
that round but
somebody was playing floors just kept
sending the drone in during this intense
fire fight like
there's like three or four different
fights happening and this one dude's
just sitting back you know sitting in
the drone but it was enough
there was so much going on that we
didn't realize and he actually downed
one of my teammates with the with the
drone um
on top of you know getting rid of
utility so it's a cool character i think
you have to have a lot of like
map awareness to really get that you
know full effectiveness whereas like
if you're playing somebody like thermite
more of a beginner character you know
you can kind of
do your own thing and help out your team
kind of when when you kind of
see fit whereas floors you kind of have
to really be aware of what's happening
totally and that brings up one of the
more interesting things about his drone
so
he has two drones as is regular drones
but then he has
four of these rotaro drones and they
can't
stop if they stop it means they're going
to explode and once you
press detonate there's about a two
second countdown and once that count
like once you activate that it is
bulletproof an enemy can't destroy it
however
if you're just driving that thing in a
room and someone sees it and shoots it
before you activate it
it'll get destroyed it won't explode
that'll just be it yeah i i kind of like
the idea
of an explosive that can't stop until
you
want to commit and blow it up that's a
neat idea uh but but i'm curious to see
how people end up
playing with this character
one other interesting thing that
happened to me was
i sent it in and almost immediately
mozzie stole it from me and i don't know
what happened to it yeah i don't know if
it frozen exploded or if they were able
to gain control of it but that is one
thing to keep
keep account of is that this this can be
stolen
as other drones can yeah and like
typical you know
i don't think every trap works against
the rotaro drone but i believe mute
still does
um so i played him on defense quite a
bit um
so that's a good counter but yeah it's
it's really funny to see like
the drone come in and it's kind of like
you know it can't stop and so you can
kind of
it's a fun game to like maneuver where
like it you make it awkward for them
as the controller to like get around but
it's a good time yeah
apart from the new character there's
also new equipment which they've added
to a handful of operators called the
gone
6 and this is a single shot secondary
that blows small holes in walls or it
destroys
enemy equipment most notably like
shields if someone throws down a
deployable shield you can shoot it
and it'll blow up it it's got some
really good sound effects
i don't know how useful it is i'm sure
some people would prefer that over a
sidearm
did you have a chance to mess around
with the gone six at all i did yeah
pretty much uh any chance that i wasn't
playing floor as i was
using a character that could use the gun
six um i played a lot of lion during the
event
um a little bit of gridlock both of
those characters have access to it
and i actually enjoyed it like um i'm
typically that
my play style is typically i like to go
around and try to get like a side flink
going and just kind of like
harass the enemy a little while like you
know a few other teammates kind of
full force like push in um and it was
great for that like finding a soft wall
to kind of
it's like a it's a it's a small hole
it's not like a giant um
like a giant ash explosive but you know
it's it's enough where you can kind of
see through and stick your gun butt
through and
and get some shots in and it was a great
way honestly to um
there was a couple times i was able to
like get rid of you know all sorts of
traps
through it i don't think i ever got a
kill through it but it's good for line
of sight you know what i mean
so and just seeing what's going on on
the other side of the wall
yeah i mean now that i think about it i
don't actually use my sidearm probably
as much as i should
anyway so i feel like gone 6 is probably
something i'll be using more of but
as we were playing like i didn't i found
it practical at times but it was just
fun to shoot yeah so i'm curious to try
out more of it but then
the final big change coming to this
season is the border map
changes now siege for a long time for
the last couple years they haven't
really been adding new maps they've been
going through and
retooling a lot of their old maps and
the same goes with border
which is interesting because border's
always been a fan favorite it's one of
my favorite maps
i think a lot of the changes they've
made are pretty smart but the big things
are that there are more soft walls
there's a couple more passageways
including a balcony
it's kind of situated above teller right
if i'm not mistaken
yeah yeah yeah it's right above tele
yeah so i i enjoyed the map changes uh
like you said borders always been one of
my favorites um they expanded bathroom
as well um so it's more viable for the
defending team
it's not so claustrophobic and it feels
like i got into several good firefights
uh
in bathroom you kind of on on both sides
of the equation and
yeah i'm digging the changes to uh to
border overall
yeah so am i i think i think they're all
good changes it doesn't
drastically change the map like we saw
with house which bumped me out a little
yeah
uh it it seems more subtle it seems
like they've watched a lot of
both you know novice and professional
siege players play that map
and they saw what needed change what
needed to work i'm curious to see what
the community thinks of it once more
people get their hands on it but right
now i i was fairly positive on it
that's all we played pretty much during
the preview and i could have easily
played more of it absolutely um i think
like you said they were subtle
with the changes they they showed
restraint i think um
whereas i'm kind of with you with those
house changes i didn't
uh you know like them as much um whereas
this just feels like
little smart ways to improve the map and
i felt like usually when i'm playing a
new
a rework because i kind of play i don't
play every single season i kind of find
myself going back every other season or
so
and i'm always like lost for the first
few matches and this was like pretty
easy to pick up like okay i know this i
know this
beyond that beyond this season we also
got a chance to take a look at
what's next for rainbow six siege and
they gave us an outline of what to
expect and i think one thing that really
stood out that a lot of people
are probably going to want to talk about
and be disappointed about
is that every single season this year
only has one operator which
for previous i think until the end of
last year uh
all siege seasons had two operators now
they're going down to one
personally as somebody who's been
playing siege for a long time i'm a
little bummed i remember when they
talked about their
goal to get 100 operators and now that
they've cut that down to one a season
i'm like that that's gonna take a while
but i see why they're doing it i think
it is because they are trying very hard
to get
newer players into siege and to make
siege less
intimidating yep and i feel like the
more operators you
add the more intimidating siege is going
to get because there's more rules
there's more gadgets there's more things
you need to know
uh round to round yeah one one word that
they brought up
when kind of talking about those changes
is accessibility for those new players
and
i think you see that i also wonder like
how much covet plays a role in
kind of the totally the the lesser
output
um but yeah i mean if i won't be too
bummed if the
operators they introduce bring
meaningful change to the game
um you know they talked about floors is
trying to help with that
20-second meta um because i feel like a
lot of times
it's kind of hit or miss for those like
two pair those pair of operators that
drop it's usually
one of them is like really viable and
the other kind of gets
sidelined sometimes so maybe with you
know more of a focus on one we can kind
of get
meaningful characters yeah i i don't
think it's a bad thing
i i totally get why they're doing it but
part of me
definitely is a little bummed i think
that's okay i'll get two at a time yeah
i think it's okay to be bummed
um but yeah i'm overall like i as far as
crimson heist goes i'm
i felt like it was a substantial amount
of changes coming that
made me excited to play the game again
because i have kind of laughs i haven't
played in a season or two and i'm
definitely like getting the itch again
yeah same with me and it seems like this
year they are definitely going to focus
more on that
on those quality of life stuff so rather
than adding content they're just going
to be focusing on
improving the game you mentioned the 20
second meta meta
earlier and that's something they walked
us through during the presentation and
they were saying how
they want less downtime in siege
it's interesting because siege does have
a lot of downtime right there's the
preparation phase when you die you're
just checking cameras and they want to
try to figure out ways to get knocked
out players more involved
in the match even while they are kicked
out and they want to try to shorten
those early windows
they were pretty vague on how they're
actually going to do that
and that is something they're going to
iterate on and test out in the test
server and they said that
this year when they have new ideas new
things they want to test they're going
to focus a lot more on putting that in
the test server and getting it in
players hands early
so they can test it out so yeah this
seems like a
a a siege 2.0 year in a weird way where
rather than adding a bunch of content
they're just doubling down
on making this shooter as solid as can
be and also
bringing in as many new players as
possible yeah i'm stoked man i'm excited
i'm ready me too i'm i'm ready for more
siege like you i took a break for a
couple seasons and
playing this and especially the changes
to border and
the new character like you're saying
does feel
does feel more significant than some
characters they've added in the past so
i'm excited to see
where that goes but anyway for more on
rainbow six siege stay tuned to gamespot
we've got news stories
and articles and other videos as well
but also be sure to check out game
informer is there anything
over there that you're working on alex
that you want to plug yeah sure thank
you
um yeah i've actually got a feature uh
going out
uh on kind of my favorite things that
are being introduced with crimson heist
and kind of uh things that were
mentioned during the roadmap
conversation so
yeah head over to youtube.com
gameinformer or justgameinformer.com
[Music]
[Music]
you